it is easy to become numb about media
bias these days so the Ingram angle is
keeping track of the worst offenders of
the week here now is charlie kirk one of
your favorites founder and president of
Turning Point USA hey Charlie
along with Chadwick more conservative
commentator and columnist for Spectator
USA right here in the studio with me
fellas thank you for joining me tonight
I appreciate it
it's hope you guys had a good
Thanksgiving now let's begin not that
the politics ends so the media gives us
a break right so let's begin with an
MSNBC contributors offensive description
of trumps even more than offensive of
Trump supporters in the midst of this
impeachment paddle the behaviors that
I'm seeing here and this is anecdotal
are very similar to the way that Isis
members are they are true believers and
this is their reality and they will not
surrender it I you know there
dead-enders Malcolm I love your attitude
as we say in Philly attitude you got it
yeah he loves the attitude there where
they were just like Isis supporters
Charlie what's your take on that
I mean it's stunning when you just think
they can't go any lower they say things
like that what I can't just comprehend
how Chris Matthews finds that to be
somehow positive or favorable but just
to insert some facts about it it's
actually President Trump and his
leadership and his administration that
were able to execute the successful raid
against al-baghdadi if they really want
to use Isis and Trump in the same
sentence they may as well use something
you know Chris Chris Matthews wouldn't
like your attitude I'll tell you that
right now
Chadwicks what's your take well I hang
out with a lot of Trump supporters and
I'm lucky I have a rare medical
condition where when I get thrown off
buildings actually bounce yeah so we
have a good laugh so they're just like
Isis Isis supporters in that respect I
think he's right actually to be honest
it's it's a remarkable just the gas
lighting that happens is the stand right
now the media is salivating over New
York Times report today that Trump is
briefed on the whistleblower complaint
before releasing aid to Ukraine to that
the only reason he released the aid is
he got caught in this whole scheme the
president decided to release the aid
when he knew his cover was blown
once they knew that the gig was up and
they were about to be discovered
steps to try to have this final
defensive well we gave up the edge so no
harm no foul
Wow yeah Charlie let me just ask you
here it's it's almost like it's
fanfiction at this point I mean what
there's nothing you can believe what's
your take on their their conspiracy
framework there yeah that's if that's
exactly the word I was going to use is
conspiracy framework I mean get caught
in order to get caught you have to
actually do something wrong he did
nothing wrong he released the aid he
gave Ukraine deadly weaponry and
armament that Barack Obama never used
what exactly is the caught that they
want to focus on they use these word
bribery the only bribery we have
evidence of or even close to it is a
former vice president's son who used to
sit on a Ukrainian gas board just
because his last name was bi made no
success or experience in the region
whatsoever
yeah Chadwick is this him is this a guy
who got caught being president is that
his crime I think he got caught being
President I think you're exactly right
that is his crime yeah and not sitting
on certain boards and having certain
friends in the Democrat Party I think
Charlie is exactly right about that as
well yeah this it's a worry because
remember not people sometimes they're
just listening only to that it's
troubling well gentlemen what about this
comment from CNN disparaging Trump
supporters I am referring to Trump's
organization and and followership as a
destructive cult where people are being
fed propaganda and they're not being
encouraged to think for themselves yeah
Charlie this is the second time we've
seen this and this is kind of new now
we've got media clearly unabashedly not
just attacking President Trump but going
after the supporters whether it's now
where Isis fighters or this kind of
nonsense
how far can this go do you think well
and you know ad that's a list of
deplorable zand flyover country and
Walmart smelly people it seems as if the
left does not just disagree with us on
policy they think we're bad people they
think as if there's something morally
wrong with conservatives we always like
to say you know we look at the left and
we say that wrong they look at us and
think we're bad it seems as if they're
continuing I don't know what kind of
electoral strategy this is just to
continue insults 60 million people and
hope to win them back but if this is
their strategy continue to do it I'm not
sure if it's gonna work yeah Chadwick I
don't think that they intended
in us back at this point I think you
might be right you know the first time I
thought one party might be acting like a
cult was during the State of the Union
when all the women congressional members
wore white that looked a little culty to
me if they want to talk about insane
death cults on one of the political
party yeah besides Americans get
passionate about politics there's no
bones about that this this dynamic of
just not even disparagement but
condemnation of your opposition is
extraordinary fellas thank you so much
charlie and Shadwick thank you for
joining me I really appreciate it guys